the administrative state is
anti-constitutional it's the rule of the
few for their own sakes a distinct and
insular class of people rather than a
trained elite corrupt and distant from
the people whom they rule
the administrative state is openly
hostile to the constitution it allows
for myriad methods of policymaking in
reality at the end of the day it
represents a return to
pre-constitutional government
the administrative state today is rather
than the aristocracy that the
progressives hoped it would be simply an
oligarchy it's the rule of the few for
their own sakes a distinct and insular
class of people rather than a trained
elite corrupt and distant from the
people whom they rule
they're supported by a coterie of
clientele groups who depend upon the
modern administrative state for
privileges and benefits
the average person in this system is
systematically and fundamentally
disenfranchised policy is not made for
his benefit and he is largely unable to
control the machinery of the state
in some the administrative state is the
antithesis of constitutional government
and cannot even live up to the
expectations of its progressive founders
the administrative state intrudes upon
even the minutest aspects of people's
lives
the federal government dictates the
amount of water that you can have in
your washing machine and in your
dishwasher the federal government
dictates the content of the light bulbs
that light up your house in the evening
they dictate the composition of the
spouts on the gas can that you use to
fill your lawnmower they've determined
that the ordinary gas can spout allows
for too many fumes to escape and so
instead they created a system which is
all but impossible for the ordinary
person to use and probably causes more
spills anyway the federal government
dictates to the manufacturers of step
ladders the angle at which the latter
must be placed when they test it for the
sake of determining its weight rating
meanwhile we might note
the administrative state seems to be
sincerely uninterested in performing the
tasks that our founding fathers expected
legitimate government to perform
major cities
have chronic amounts of unsolved murders
which they never seemed to bother to get
to in many cases the city of detroit
discovered several years ago a backlog
of thousands of unprocessed rape kits
that took more than a decade to finish
the mayor of portland oregon seems
perfectly content to allow antifa to
take over the streets of the city and to
enforce the laws themselves and portland
is one of a number of examples of
progressive cities on the west coast
which also seem perfectly content to
allow their cities to become mountains
of drugs and human excrement
at the national level our government or
at least much of our government seems to
be deeply unconcerned for maintaining
our territorial integrity in the face of
thousands if not millions of illegal
immigrants coming into the country and
thus unconcerned with protecting the
basic sovereignty of the united states
so that's another way that we can think
about the anti-constitutionalism
of the administrative state that is to
say
it inverts its priorities it becomes
intensely focused on things that
legitimate government ought not to do
and it neglects the things that just
government should do
you